something is emerging from the mariana
transient it does not belong on this
planet
if aliens lived in the deepest place in
the ocean
what would they look like
how would they communicate with one
another
and
what would happen if we dared to contact
them
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there were aliens at the
bottom of the mariana trench
there's a reason why the idea of aliens
living at the bottom of the sea keeps
popping up in popular culture
many of us are far more afraid of what
lies down there than whatever's looking
down at us from up in space
after all eighty percent of the ocean is
still unmapped and unexplored
we have better maps of the moon mars and
venus than we do of our sea floor
the most mysterious part of our oceans
is the mariana trench
its deepest point the challenger deep
stretches 11 kilometers down
the mariana trench is anything but a
great vacation spot
no light is able to reach its bottom and
temperatures are just a few degrees
above freezing
not to mention it's crushingly high
water pressure
so
how could aliens survive the deepest
spot in the ocean
the water pressure at the bottom of the
mariana trench is over 1 000 times the
atmospheric pressure that you're used to
at sea level
this kind of pressure would crush
anything
even the toughest deep sea robots we've
ever built
but
some living things managed to adapt and
thrive under such pressing conditions
like translucent snail fish and sea
cucumbers
the heidel snailfish known as the
deepest living fish
flourishes at depths of over 8
kilometers
unlike you deep sea fish don't have
pockets to store air in their bodies
that oxygen inside the lungs is what
gives you the feeling of pressure
whenever you take a dive
no air means this fish has a higher
tolerance to the weight of all that
water above it
whatever aliens were lurking down below
would share the same characteristic
storing air just wouldn't be their thing
but what would they do for food
well it's likely they'd imitate their
seafloor neighbors once again
deep sea creatures gorge on the decaying
remains of microbes algae or animals
from above
our sunken ships might be their version
of a surprise buffet
any extraterrestrial life down at the
pit of the trench would probably eat
similar food
they'd burrow into the biggest carcasses
they could find and consume what's left
from the inside out
like a giant hagfish does
or they might possess enormous mouths
and expandable stomachs
allowing them to catch and digest large
quantities of food as they move
and those big mouths of theirs would
also be filled with long fangs pointed
inward
this would enable them to catch and hold
on to other deep sea creatures or you
know any other prey that just so happens
to dive a little too far from the
surface
hey don't judge them in a habitat as
precarious as the mariana trench
aliens would need to capitalize on any
and all sources of nutrition
they'd also have to go the extra mile in
order to let one another know that
they're out there in the pitch dark
that's because sunlight can only travel
up to one kilometer into the ocean
anywhere deeper than that and
you wouldn't be able to see a thing
so
how would our underwater aliens put the
notice out that they're around
well two ideas by sound and by light
they produce themselves
like fireflies deep sea creatures are
able to produce and emit their own light
thanks to a process called
bioluminescence
with it aliens would be able to connect
with each other through specific
lighting patterns
for long distance communication they
could send out sound waves across
enormous distances in the water like the
humpback whale who's able to sing in the
caribbean and be heard off the west
coast of ireland 6 400 kilometers away
now
what would first contact with this
underwater species look like for us
well we'd have to get there first
we'd need a vessel strong enough to
withstand the constantly intensifying
pressure
the tiniest of cracks would squash you
and your submarine faster than you can
say a human jam
once down there we'd have to take into
account that living at the bottom of the
sea
would be like living on another planet
if aliens existed in the otherworldly
depths of the mariana trench this entire
time
they may not want to be friendly
neighbors
and the darkness alone would make it
difficult to locate and study our
subjects
before approaching these
extraterrestrials we'd have to assess
their communication style first
slowly and patiently
we'd need to understand how they
interact with their environment too
that is assuming they don't feel
threatened by our presence and decide to
do something about it
trust goes both ways when you're trying
not to be crushed or eaten in the name
of science
i mean it wouldn't be the first time we
humans discovered a new species and
thought
cool i wonder if it tastes like chicken
ah i doubt eating an alien would be
great for your digestion but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]